MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
to this short recording
of our 8.701 lecture.
With this short
discussion, I want
to introduce the teaching staff
to this course, the instructor,
which is myself, Markus
Klute, and our TA Justin.
So I am faculty in the
physics department since 2009.
I received my diploma, which
is my undergraduate study,
in Germany and also my PhD
from the University in Bonn.
I-- with research on the
OPAL experiment, which
is an experiment on the large
electron positron collider
at CERN, on the ATLAS
experiment, which
is in the Large Hadron
Collider, also at CERN, and also
on the D0 experiment, which
was one of the experiments
at the Tevatron in
Chicago at Fermilab.
So after my PhD, I joined
MIT as a postdoc, and later
as a research scientist.
And I worked on
the CDF experiment
at the Tevatron and
the CMS experiment
at the Large Hadron Collider.
In 2007, I accepted a
faculty position in Germany,
where I spent about a year,
before coming back to MIT.
It's not a surprise--
this is CV--
that I-- my interest
is in particle physics
at the energy frontier.
I work on design,
the construction,
the commissioning of detectors.
We made major contribution
to the hydronic calorimeter
in CMS and also the
data acquisition system.
Most recently, I was leading the
software and computing project
within the CMS experiment.
Most exciting-- the physics.
And in 2012, we were able
to discover the Higgs
boson with the CMS experiment.
And so ATLAS had a
similar experience.
And since then, we were able to
look more deeply, more closely
into how the Higgs boson--
case.
We were able to show
couplings to W and Z bosons,
to photons via loops of
top quarks and W bosons.
But then we looked
into whether or not
Higgs bosons couple of
fermions like electrons.
So we were able to show
couplings to taus--
those are the heaviest
brothers of the electrons--
and most recently,
couplings of Higgs
bosons to muons, which are
second-generation particles.
So this exploitation and
exploration of the Higgs boson
is really at the center
of my research portfolio.
We don't just spend our
time analyzing the data
from the LHC, but we
also look whether or not
new machines can teach
us important information
about the Higgs boson.
When I'm not doing research,
I have a little family
who I like to spend time with.
I used to play soccer quite
a bit, and also tennis.
But when you get older, those
kind of contact interactions
are not very useful
for you anymore.
You get injured quite a bit.
So I left it to the running
part of those activities.
And I picked up
running quite a bit.
In a couple of weeks
into the semester,
everyone, my and the first
virtual Boston Marathon--
so some of those videos might
have a little bit of a fighting
face in front of you.
But I hope everything
is going well.
Our teaching TA is Justin.
Justin is a graduate
student in my group.
He's in the second year.
He took this very class with
Mike Williams last fall.
So he should be well-prepared
to guide you and answer
your questions.
He received his
undergraduate degree
from the University of
Michigan at Ann Arbor,
where he was working
on the g-2 experiment.
We'll probably talk about
those kind of experiments
later in the class as well.
Recently, he has been
taking up running as well.
But he spends, also, time
on rowing and hiking.
So we, both of us, look
forward to meeting you
in this first class
on Tuesday and hope
that we have a good time
together with 8.701.